françois mitterrand inaugure demain la
toute nouvelle usine d'airbus industrie
près de toulouse un bâtiment unique en
europe la chaîne disparaît on va
installer notamment des robots une usine
qui va construire un avion qui n'a pas
encore volé grâce à l'informatique les
a330 et a340 ont déjà été commandés sur
plan à plus de 200 exemplaires line que
nous présente en avant première
olivier loubet la plus grande usine
aéronautique jamais construite en europe
aussi haute que l'arc de triomphe elle
contiendrait 80 courts de tennis
la balle de match sabelli si airbus les
a340 et a330
les longs et moyens courriers le terrain
c'est celui de l'aérospatiale qui pour
la première fois construit une usine
adaptée un avion sous les 6 hectares de
cette surface couverte les gros airbus
plus de 60 mètres de long est
d'envergure prendront place c'est aussi
une philosophie nouvelle d'assemblage
qui est introduite d'une chaîne linéaire
où l'avion avance on passe à une chaîne
modulaire des petits postes de montage
du décès indépendants les uns des autres
mais la grande nouveauté c'est l'entrée
en force des automatismes et de la
robotisation comme sur ce poste 40
étapes essentielles ou la voilure est
assemblée au fuselage et ce ne sont pas
moins de huit robots à commande
numérique qui assureront les opérations
de perçage et d'un les agents tokyo des
3200 points d'attache de la voilure
de même le post 40 où se fait la
jonction général de l'avion fait appel à
une immense machine à coudre automatique
perçage riz le tage encollage c'est le
couture âge orbitale qui fonctionne
grâce à des balises réparties sur le
fuselage bref la productique s'installe
dans l'assemblage un outil sophistiqué
au service de la productivité des
conditions de travail lusine clément a
d'ailleurs c'est la réalisation d'un
rêve c'est encore un pari ambitieux
atteindre à l'horizon 93 une cadence de
cet à 340 par mois l'assemblage du
premier long courrier avions d'essai
commencera la mi décembre mais le pari
d'ores et déjà gagné c'était construire
l'usiné en deux ans et demi
enfin